hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar solutions for myeloid cell
research from periphery to brain
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltenny biotech to learn more
visit miltennybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
nizar youssef global product manager
immunology and immuno oncology at
miltoni biotech and dr alisa net global
product manager for neuroscience at
miltoni biotech
nazar and elisa you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the car introduction and
hello everyone from my side today my
colleague lisa and i are going to take
you on the journey through all solutions
for my last cell research i will cover
the first part and we'll be talking
about solutions for myeloid cells in
their periphery
elisa will then continue the
presentation and talk about solutions
for myeloid cells in the brain we hope
that you enjoyed this webinar
this is our agenda i will start with a
brief introduction about myeloid cells
then we'll talk about our sample
preparation solutions for myeloid cells
in general afterwards we go through the
solutions
for different myeloid cell types
and
today
due to the sake of time i will focus on
solutions for monocytes
macrophages and neutrophils while elisa
will focus on solutions for brain
macrophages namely microglia
myeloid cell side are vase and beautiful
they process different shapes and size
as you observe here in in this slide
myeloid cells are present everywhere you
find in in the liver copper cells and in
3x cells
if you look at the spleen you find red
macrophages dendritic cells as well as
granulocytes
in the lung alveolar macrophages also
and also dendritic cells
present in the blood are granulocytes
monocytes and dendritic cells
and
an example of myeloid cells in the bones
are osteoclast
and the protein
we have protein in macrophages and
dendritic cells
in the skin we have the famous
langerhans celsius and skin macrophages
and in the most important
organ in the body the brain we have
tissue resident macrophages is
specifically named microglia and also
perivascular macrophages
and in tumors we have tumor associated
macrophages
terms
tumor associated neutrophils tans and
myeloid suppressor
mdscs
so please note that these are examples
are not restrictions the widest presence
of myeloid cells in different organs
immediately gives us the indication that
these cells are have important roles
so let's have a look together at some
examples of myeloid cells functions
myeloid cells have important functions
in health and disease for example in
healthy state
tissue macrophages are highly
specialized in removal of dead cells and
cellular debris and thus maintain proper
organ function
moreover macrophages are involved in
metabolism of iron calcium lipids and
other substance and contribute to the
maintenance of this substance in the
body
in case of infections macrophages engulf
pathogens and destroy them while
atrophies are highly motile and quickly
react to chemical signals such as
cytokines secreted by other immune cells
like macrophages during infections
and migrate to the site of infections
neutrophils have cool methods to attract
and kill pathogens including the
formation of neutrophil extracellular
traps
as you observe here
in this image
neutrophil can also do phagocytosis to
destroy pathogens or they can release
antimicrobial agents from their
groundings to destroy embedding
particles
in case of cancer myeloid cells can have
positive or negative outcomes they can
contribute to tumor progression by
suppressing antitumor immune cells
here i'm referring to milo derived
suppressor cells mds trees
and research has also shown that
macrophages may have cytotoxic activity
to call tumors to kill human cells
directly
and myeloid cells have also been shown
to affect cancer therapy in positive and
negative way
now
let's talk about the sample preparation
solutions for myeloid cell research
so careful preparation leads to to happy
end
and here i'm going to show solutions for
human and mouse myeloid cells
so what are the challenges for myeloma
cell sample preparation
well time is an important factor some
researchers process several samples
which requires long preparation time
having low number of viable cells is big
is a big challenge in many experiments
and also every top degree degradation
due to improper sample preparation is a
problem for downstream applications for
example flow analysis
or functional analysis where the cell
surface receptors are needed
having inconsistent yield
is is the challenge for reproducible
results
so
what is the solutions or what is this
with what are the solutions as a
solutions for these
challenges
i'll introduce you our gentlemax
technology and associated tools
the gentlemax dissociator is a benchtop
instrument for semi-automated
dissociation of tissues into single cell
suspensions or thorough homogenates
we have two types of unique gentlemax
tubes used with the instrument and this
enable the time saving and easy
dissociation
or homogenization of tissues in a closed
system
so the combination of mechanical
disruption
using the gentlemax and it's different
tubing systems with the enzymatic
digestion using optimized
and highly purified enzymes and this
technology enables efficient
dissociation
so speed
viability epitope preservation and
reproducibility are guaranteed
now i'd like to show you floor cytometry
data
generated after dissociation of
different mouse tissues single cell
suspensions of splain
lung
lamina prop here and tumor tissues were
obtained with the gentle max and the
associated
dissociation kit
as you observe here
this enabled obtaining of high viable
cells
which allow the detection of dc
subsets
so cell surface epitopes were well
preserved for labeling with
antibodies against relevant phenotype
markers
now i will carry on and talk about
solutions for monocytes and macrophages
here i will cover solutions for human
and mouse monocytes and macrophages
and we start with the solutions for
human samples
here we have wide range of solutions for
sample obtained from different materials
from peripheral blood whole blood buffy
court lrc liquid packs or pbmcs
solutions for monocytes and macrophages
separation shown here in blue
cell calcium solutions for monocyte
differentiation into macrophages
solution for macrophage polarizations
this includes cytokines and growth
factors shown here
in red
different antibodies for the analysis of
t cells shown here
in green
now let's start with some of the cell
suppression challenges cell sorting
requires long time
long number of viable cells which
affects various downstream applications
and a specific cell activation you don't
want to have that on your
separated cells for reliable downstream
applications having few cells of
interest after separation is a challenge
for conducting for conducting your
experiments
now let's talk about our cell
suppression solutions for these
challenges
we offer several solutions for the
isolation of monocyte substance
for different starting materials
yeah inclu solutions for
pan monocytes resolution of pan
monocytes we have variable options for
dissolution of classical monocytes and a
solution for the isolation of
non-classical monocytes
in this slide you observed isolation of
monocytes from human pbmcs using cd14
macrobeads
which is a positive selection method
positive selection means
that during separation monocytes are
magnetically
labeled and remain retained
within the column
while unlabeled cells flow
through
after washing step the column is removed
from the magnetic field of the separator
and target cells are eluted
from the column
as you observe
in this flow analysis results shown here
high purity and high recovery of the
isolated cd14 positive cells have been
have been obtained
another option for monocyte isolation is
by using the pan monocyte isolation kit
the pan monocyte isolation kit is an
indirect resolution method for the
isolation of untouched monocytes from
human pbmcs
it allows the enrichment of classical
non-classical intermediate monocytes so
by using this kit you get your highly
pure monocytes by the depletion
of the magnetically labeled non-target
cells
the electro microscopy results you
observe here is from a recent
publication in which they showed that
monocyte
isolated from carbon 19 patients have
dis dysfunctional mitochondria
and this work monocytes were isolated
using our pan monocyte isolation kit
and as you observe here no monocyte
dysfunctions have been detected in the
in the control before i introduce you
to our threat from solutions for
monocytes let me say some few words
about
our straight from technology a thread
from technology enables the suppression
of highly pure cells directly from
different blood sources
with all the benefits of max
microbeads as well as
easy and faster enrichment of leukocytes
so no need for density gradient no cell
counting no washing and no erythrocyte
lysis
needed
and this is an example of multiple
separations from one sample
using straight from technology
this technology permits multiple cell
isolation of cd14 positive monocytes
cdit's positive t cells
and cd4 positive t cells
from the same sample in just one hour
time and as you observe here we have
several
straight from
technologies for the isolation of
monocytes starting from different
materials
a fitting solution i would like to
introduce here for line sample processes
processing is cell separation via
automation
uh the multi-max
cells 24 separator nicely fits for this
purpose it has multiple practical
features
from flexible sample scalability to
processing of large sample volume
in short in short time
now an alternative option for the
isolation of human and mouse monocytes
and macrophages is via the cd14 mac
repeats here these macrobeats are
developed for the isolation or depletion
of human and mouse cells based on their
cd11 the expression
and in these plots
you observe cd11 positive signal of
mouse spillinus site before separation a
spilinocyte without cd11 positive shells
these are the shells in the flow through
flow through and nicely and the nicely
isolated cd11
c11b positive
mouse cells here on the very right
next cd 163 micro bit kit human this can
allow the enrichment of human cells from
for example healthy or tumor tissues
based on the expression of the
cd163
antigen cd 163 is most abundantly
suppressed biomaterial tissue
macrophages and peripheral blood
monocytes
you observed
here result from 100 cd from 100
from cd 163 positive cells isolated from
ovarian carcinoma sample using
the cd163 microbead kit after isolation
the cells were stained with cd
pa
and cd 206 which antibodies are analyzed
by fluorocytometry
the isolated cells are ready to go for
different downstream applications
now let's move to the solutions for
mouse monocytes
and macrophages
and here we also offer several options
for different sample sources
for from cell separation to cell culture
to cell analysis
and these are solutions for myeloid
cells
in in the lung
now anti-for
f4 80 macrobeats ultra pure is very good
option for the isolation of mouse
macrophages from spleen or tumor tissue
and here below
is flow data showing the separation of f
480 positive cells from spleen and tumor
tissue
in this slide i would like to show you
that macrophage is isolated by anti
f4 80 macro beats ultra pure ideal for
downstream molecular analysis
macrophages isolated from tumors
from breast cancer xenograph using mtf4
80 micro bit ultra pure were analyzed
for innate immunity pathways
using the nano string platform
the general message of this result
is that treatment with different drugs
modulated macrophages gene signature
or the isolation of mouse monocytes and
macrophages from blood or lymphoid
tissue we have the cd11b macrobeast
ultra pure
yourself here in the dot plots
cd c11b positive cells isolate from this
plane using cd11b microbeads ultra pure
mouse
stained with cd11b fitch and
antigr1p antibodies and analyzed by
fluorocytometry
in the first plot
the cells
shows the cells before separation in the
second dot plot shows the flow through
without the cd11b positive cells that
are returned in the column and the third
dot plot shows that the isolated c11b
positive cells
so to wrap up the section of monocytes
and macrophages
our solutions cell separation solutions
for these cells guarantee
time saving
optimal viability and functionality
as well as review disability
and let's start with solutions for
neutrophils from human models
here you observe our options for human
neutrophils research
the challenges i mentioned in my
previous slides for other myeloid cell
types exist here as well so i don't need
to go through it in details again so
what are the solutions for these
challenges in case of human neutrophils
well let's have a look together at our
max express technology
human neutrophils are usually obtained
by density gradient centrifugation
however
death method is exceedingly time
consuming
and frequently results in neutrophil
populations that are contaminated by
other leukocytes mainly the xenophiles
with the maxopress technology
untouched human neutrophils can be
isolated from whole blood within 20
minutes
and in this method erythrocytes are
aggregated and
sedimented
and
non-target cells are removed by
immunomagnetic depletion with the max
express beads
and the
untouched highly pure
target cells
can then be easily collected
as you observe here in in this
illustration
in this results you observe that human
neutrophils are efficiently isolated
from all blood
using maxi-suppressed neutrophil
isolation kit in the upper dot plots you
observe the cells before separation and
in the lower dot plot you observe the
cells after separations
here
after separation the cells were stained
with cd15 and cd16 antibodies which are
markers for human neutrophils
this kit allows isolation of neutrophils
with high purity recovery and viability
in a short time period and here are all
the nice features listed
here the functionality of neutrophil
isolated with max express technology was
tested the neutrophil isolated with max
technology show high ross production
open up on stimulation with e coli red
bar and pma light blue bar as compared
to the neutrophils isolated with the
density gradient method
this data was obtained from flow
cytometry analysis
in this slide i would like to show you
data from
application where it was assessed
whether oxidative metabolism might be
present in neutrophils from cancer
patients
in this work they isolated neutrophils
from peripheral blood using marxist
suppressed neutrophil isolation kit
and analysis revealed that patients
harboring ovarian cancers had an
increased proportion
of neutrophils with intermediate
expression of cd10 and cd16
which is characteristics previously
reported as
a negative of
immature phenotype
and
immature cd
10 intermediate neutrophils possess
greater mitochondrial
content
and cancer patients neutrophils possess
greater atp
sensates
dependent ocr oci states for oxygen
consumption
rate compared to healthy
controls
now let's go to the solutions for mouse
neutrophils
here we also have rich solutions for
different tissues
now the anti ly 6g macrobeats ultra pure
for the isolation of mass neutrophils
from lung tissue blood or bone marrow
and in these top plots you observe the
cells before separation and the
effectively isolated neutrophils as
indicated by
cg11b and anti-ly6g staining
the neutrophysia isolation kit is an
alternative option to the anti-ly 60
micro beats ultra pure if you are
interested in obtaining untouched mouse
neutrophils
since in this kit the untarget cells are
magnetically depleted and the target
cells are isolated without magnetic
labeling
again
here the cells before
before isolation and the isolated
neutrophils are
shown
now these are results from a very recent
publication where they conducted
transcription analysis of neutrophils
isolated from mouse liver and blood
the dot plots are represented floor
cytometry profiles of isolated
neutrophils on the left forward versus
side scatterplots on the right
ly6g versus c11b staining profiles of
the neutrophils the graphs on the right
show gene expression analysis on mouse
neutrophils
so
i'm getting close to the end of my
presentation and in my last slides i
will talk about our cell analysis
solutions for myeloid cells so
once you get your your cells of interest
of course you want to analyze them
here in the shell analysis part we also
have several challenges
one of the challenges could be that the
antibodies are not highly specific so
they are not effective in capturing the
antigen of interest moreover having high
background signal where antibodies
detect signals that are not specific to
the antigen
one of the reasons for high background
signals is non-specific binding of
antibodies to fc receptors
found on myeloid cells such as
macrophages monocytes and dendritic
cells
so let's have a look at our solutions
for this part
you'll be able to do precise analysis of
your myeloid cells with our rear
affinity antibodies
these are recombinantly engineered
antibodies so not a lot consistent
they are highly pure
and they consist of one universal
isotope control so one human igg one
and most importantly these antibodies
are engineered to lack fc part which
lead to prevention of unspecific binding
this is an example of human macrophages
phenotype using re-affinity antibodies
the results show that cd
163 cd 209 and cd200r are highly
suppressed in m2 macrophages while cd68
is highly expressed in m1 macrophage
the complete story including solutions
for macrophage polarization cell culture
and phenotyping is included in an
abnormal
application node
i inserted the link for it
here so for more details about this
topic please have a look at it
now i'll wrap up the first part of this
webinar and here are some take home
messages the gentile max dissociate
dissociators and the dissociation kits
are here for optimal myeloid cell sample
preparation we have optimized separation
of myeloid cells positive isolation and
touch isolation or straight from
automation multi-max auto marks are
mostly possible with our
cell separation options
our the cells isolated
with our cell separation technology are
suitable for many downstream analysis
omics cell culture flow phenotyping et
cetera et cetera
and precise analysis of myeloid cells
with re-affinity antibody so consistency
standardization and high specific
signals
and most importantly our experts are
happy to guide you through the entire
workflow for myeloid cell research and
here i will hand over to my colleague
eliza and i thank you for your attention
okay thank you nizar and welcome also
from my side i will present to you now
the solutions for brain myeloid cells
so this here is the human brain and as
most of you know these here are the main
neural cell types we have neurons
astrocytes and oligodendrocytes
and there are actually two more types of
cells in the brain these are the
microclear and macrophages
and although microglia are also called
tissue resident macrophage they are
actually quite different
so you can see here that these cells
reside in different knees in the brain
micro clear are located in the brain
parenchyme whereas classical macrophages
can be rather found close to vessels at
the choroid plexus or in the meninges
each cell type expresses a unique set of
markers
and has slightly different function
so
for now let's focus on the microclear
in general they have several functions
as you can see here
in the healthy brain microclear support
urinal development and survival
promote synapse formation and remodeling
modulate neural activity or phagocytosed
dead cells and myelin
whereas in the case of a tissue damage
or neuroinflammation a microclear can
get quickly activated and
phagocytosynapsis which may lead to
neurodegeneration
or can activate astrocytes by releasing
pro-inflammatory cytokines
so now the big question is what's the
best way to study microclear cells
if you've worked with microglia before
you maybe know that isolation can be
sometimes tricky you can either sort
those cells or have mixed clear culture
but actually both approaches need a
rather harsh tissue homogenization
which can stress the cells
and moreover cultivation takes around
two weeks especially if you need high
cell numbers
additionally if you've ever dissociated
the adult brain you maybe encountered
some problems due to the high amount of
debris and blood vessels
and to tackle all of these problems
let me introduce you now to our
workflows for neural cell analysis
so as you can see here we have a
dedicated workflow when analyzing the
brain
it goes from sample preparation over to
cell separation and can be followed by
say cultivation or analysis depending on
the age of the animal we recommend a
neural tissue dissociation kit for
neonatal samples
or our other dissociation kit for the
iodide brain
we have more products for isolation and
analysis that i will present to you
further in the following slides
and additionally you also have the
option to follow our imaging workflow
that allows you to clear whole brains or
hemispheres
and image these organs in 3d with our
ultra microscope blades but for today i
want to focus on our cellular workflow
so let's start with sample preparation
in the first step
the gentlemax octane associated with
heaters
helps you with a standardized and
automated dissociation
it uses a mechanical disruption and
enzymatic digestion
and thereby performs a gentle and
efficient brain association
and as i mentioned earlier adult brain
tissue is a bit tricky to work with
because it can generate huge amounts of
cell debris and red blood cells
which then hampers downstream
applications such as cell isolation cell
culture or single cell sequencing
and our adult brain association kit
works together with the gentlemax often
associated with heaters
and includes a step for debris removal
and red blood cell lyses
this then helps to remove the debris
efficiently
and also removes the red blood cells
without the need of performing animal
perfusion
as you can see also here in the figure
it results then in a high yield of pure
neural cells
after the sample cleaning you are able
to isolate the microclear with our cd11b
microbeads
this magnetic separation technology is a
gentle and fast way to obtain your cells
of interest from the cell suspension
it takes less than an hour and it will
result in a viability of around 95
percent and the purity of up to 98
percent
i guess most of you have heard of this
product already since milton is famous
for the max technology and actually the
cdlfb microbeads are also well known in
the field
then cells isolated from our workflow
highly viable and can be even cultured
afterwards
so for this we offer a serum free
culture cell culture medium
and optimize supplements to cultivate
not only microclear but also neurons
astrocytes or oligodendrocytes
this can be especially useful if you are
interested in a co-culture of several
cell types
the serum free formula prevents the high
variation between the experiments that
can normally result from using different
fcs slots
and to boost your microclear culture we
offer high quality cytokines like the
mcsf that will increase your cell
culture yield greatly
if you are working with plc-derived
neural cells we also have the optimized
stem max plc proxino free media that
allows for a weekend free feeding
schedule
so
we also offer various antibodies for
neural cell applications
which are suitable for flow as well as
for immunofluorescence
some of them can be used with a very
fast protocol and only need around 10
minutes incubation time so this is then
actually quite nice and can save you
also some time in the lab
additionally we are also in the process
of switching our hybridomas to
recombinantly engineered antibodies
which will result result then in a
higher a lot too lot consistency and
less background staining
and now i would like to show you some
highlighted publications that may
help you develop your own protocols
so the first one was from a customer
which was published last year as a star
protocol by the lab of stacy bilbo
they described step by step how to
isolate viable micro clear with our
cd11b microbeads from the idiot mouse or
even the human brain
and for anyone that is interested in
this method or is working with human
tissue i can greatly recommend this
paper
but if you're more into plc derived
cells i would like to present you this
publication
the study was published beginning of
this year by renzo marcus and his group
they developed a new method to
differentiate human plcs into microclear
and then transplant them into the mouse
brain
this way they are able to study human
microclear cells in their normal
environment
for these analysis they used our adult
brain association kit our antibodies and
most importantly the max quant title
cell sorter which is an instrument for
very gentle
cell sorting that is based on microchip
technology
and in the last paper i want to
introduce you to
the my ultra microscope blaze that i've
also mentioned before in my previous
slides
this fully automated light sheet
microscope can image large or multiple
samples using cutting edge optics
in this publication here they use the
ultra microscope to study the cleared
mouse brain in alzheimer's disease to
quantify plaques and thereby help to
find new approaches to treat this
disease
and
before we come to an end of this
presentation i would also like to
mention shortly our specific products
for the inflamed brain
for several disease models it is
beneficial to also analyze infiltrating
immune cells in addition to the neural
cells and for this we offer the
multi-tissue dissociation kit and the
set of different immune cell microbeads
in the case of eae which is experimental
autoimmune enzyme
encephalomyelitis which is a model for
multiple sclerosis this workflow can
then easily help to isolate and analyze
neural tissue
so here you see an example of isolated
immune cells from a brain of an eae
mouse with our inflamed brain workflow
you can clearly appreciate the different
cell types that are present in the
inflamed brain after the blood brain
barrier got leaky and immune cells were
able to infiltrate the brain
and this workflow can be even used for
the analysis of
immune cells from small tissues like the
spinal cord as you can see here in these
plots
and with this i will come to a summary
of my second part
i hope i could show you that um the
other brain association kit and the
gentlemax octane associated with heaters
allow for standardized gentle and
efficient utter brain dissociation
which results in a highly viable single
cell suspension that is free of debris
and red blood cells and that is suitable
for different downstream
applications the max microbeads and the
max column technology enables an easy
and fast isolation of pure viable and
functional microglia
the max quantity sales sorter allows for
microchip based cell sorting in a fully
closed and sterile cartridge system
this gentle method is especially suited
for sorting of fragile neural cells like
microclear
and
last with the ultra microscope blaze you
are able to image large or multiple
samples in an easy and automated way
3d imaging of the cleared brain allows
you to visualize the location and
connection between the different neural
cells
and with this
i'm at the end
and i want to thank you for your
attention i hope i could show you our
dedicated solutions for your myeloid
research and now please don't hesitate
to ask if you if there are still open
questions and for sure you can also
always contact us afterwards
thank you nazar and elisa for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
i would like to isolate human
neutrophils from whole blood both normal
density and low density neutrophils
would it be possible to do that with the
express kit you presented
um well with the maxis press whole
neutrophil isolation kit human
are not i mean neutrophils are not
isolated based on density so therefore
both normal density neutrophils and low
density neutrophils should be isolated
so and in the maxi suppressed technology
the aggregated erythrocytes are
sedimented at the bottom of the tube so
whereas non-target cells are
magnetically labeled and adhere to the
tube was as as long as the tube is
placed in in the magnet
so i don't see any difficulties for
getting your neutrophils of interest
using this biscuit yes
thank you
next question
i am trying to isolate infiltrating
monocytes from inflammatory adult rat
brain from the hippocampus what is the
best option what is the best antigen to
distinguish them from microglia
okay i think this i can answer this or
try to answer
um yeah it's a bit tricky to distinguish
monocytes from micro clear right since
they're quite similar
and we don't have microbeads for red
monocytes so it wouldn't work
with microbeads and magnetic isolation
but what what i would suggest is to use
for example the title cell sorter so you
could sort your cells and you could use
different kind of markers so either you
go for c11b cd45 high you could also go
for li-6c
high or ccr2 high and if you want to be
sure
um to kind of
omit all microclear you could go for
tmem190 low because this marker is quite
unique for a microclear
and
if this marker is low it should be a
monocyte so you could try those
options
for sorting but i think magnetic cell
isolation wouldn't work in this case
because those two cell types are too
similar in case of the inflamed brain
um
i hope this this helps you a bit but for
sure you can also write me and i can
also try to send you additional material
to those products
great thank you
next question
are there differences in the downstream
applications of the different monocytes
isolation kits or microbeads for example
for the differentiation of monocytes
into macrophages
i'll go for that yeah no not at all
so using either positive isolation of
monocytes with for example cd14
macrobeast or untouched isolation with
monocyte isolation kits you will be able
to differentiate the isolated monocytes
in calcium into macrophages
of course with the help of specific
cytokines and and stimulation factors
it's just a matter of preference some
researchers have long experience with
positive isolation and prefer to stay
with it and others are used to the
untouched isolation methods and so
moreover they there there are good
literature available yeah so where
researchers
uh are using our different modified
isolation methods to isolate monocytes
and differentiate them into into
macrophages here so
this is you can have a look at it in
pubmed yeah
great thank you
next question
you presented straight from products for
the isolation of cells from human blood
sources
do you have straight from solutions for
the isolation of cells from mouse tumor
tissue
yeah this is actually very very
interesting yeah very nice question yeah
no we we don't have a straightforward
solutions for mouse tumor tissues yet
yeah so however we are working on mouth
tissue straight from solutions for
example for the isolation of myeloid
cells from mouse spleen so please stay
stay tuned
great thank you
next question
any solution for microglia cells counts
do you have any solution for that
um yeah thanks for the question i'm not
100 sure what is meant so maybe you can
also uh elaborate a bit on this question
but basically um
[Music]
if you use the c11b beads for the for
the isolation of my nuclear you get
quite high numbers um
if you are
if you are kind of uh
[Music]
need like a high
cell count or higher number of
microclear and
also then of course it depends on what
brain region you use
and um
basically then also on the age of the
animal
but
please if you if you can
put another question and explain a bit
and then i can try to to answer
great thank you
um
well we're waiting for that our next
question is can you elaborate on the
activation status of monocytes after
magnetic isolation
actually yeah this question is is quite
common yeah we got it
so often well our internal data some of
i mean some of these data is available
online in our select the best brochure
yeah so this data confirmed that
monocyte as relation with the max
technology does not lead to the
activation of these cells
so the advantage of our max technology
is the minimum labeling maximum 30
percent of the surface epitopes will be
bound by antibodies and also the the
microbeads are tiny
so therefore they do not lead to
cross-linking or triggering of surface
receptors and thus
the activation of of these cells
so and moreover this is also
proved by publications for example where
monocyte isolated using max technology
from healthy controls did not show
activation of inflammatory markers
thank you
next question
why is it so difficult to isolate cells
from the adult brain
um yeah so as i try to explain a bit in
my slides um
basically the older the mouse gets or
the older the brain is the more
vascularized and more blood red blood
cells are there and also you have more
neurons this means more myelination
around the neurons and in the end
you end up with more myelin debris and
more
red blood cells and this can hamper your
downstream applications so
either if you would do a directly flow
analysis you would really get a lot of
events and it might be very difficult to
analyze your cells of interest it
wouldn't be really pure
or if you use
microbead
isolation then
it could also block the the binding and
then you would also not have a great
result or a high yield so that's why
um
this adult brain association kit that we
developed is specifically for the adult
brain and it tackles those two problems
so
you don't have to worry about those two
debris and red blood cells and you get a
quite pure and high sale yield in the
end
great thank you
next question
what are potential other downstream
applications of the isolated cells
um
so
in case of
microclear so after the microclear cells
after you isolate them from the brain
i mean what i showed mainly were the
fair culturing right but
you can of course also go for other
applications such as single cell
sequencing so we made sure
to collaborate with tennix genomics and
really
check that our workflow is compatible
with their single cell sequencing so
that you can or you have the option also
with this established workflows of ours
to further analyze your cells and then
um do a single size sequencing for
example so this would be also another
option that i really haven't mentioned
much yet but it's also possible
thank you
next question
how is the max quant title cell sorter
used for the analysis of psc derived
microglia
um so this was also um something that i
didn't go so much into detail um
basically
the
the title
was used in this case to
sort the microclear
especially before transplantation
and
[Music]
the good thing about this is
the title uses a system
like a cartridge system which makes the
whole process sterile
so this was then really helpful in this
specific paper or protocol because um
enzo also needed to
transplant cells back into
immunodeprived mice so of course for
this they had to be quite sterile not to
cause any uh further inflammation
um
exactly and that's how the title uh was
really helpful for his study
of the psc derived microclear
thank thank you
next question
can you elaborate a bit on the imaging
workflow
uh yeah sure so um the imaging workflow
um
i also didn't really show it i mean i
just showed it uh shortly in the
beginning um basically um
it's you can you can
um
image and analyze uh hemispheres or the
whole brain
and the workflow would be that you start
by staining the organ
with your antibodies of choice and we
are
constantly increasing our set of
antibodies that are especially made for
3d analysis
next step would be the clearing so for
this we also have a clearing kit
which is quite easy to follow and you
don't have to go through the thousands
of protocols that are available
on the internet and then obviously in
the last step you would image the brain
or the hemisphere and
with this ultra microscope blaze that i
presented it's really nice you can image
several samples in one row it's quite
automated so you can have like a batch
analysis
and imaging and then you in the end you
get really nice 3d
videos or images
of your brain and it's really helpful
for the connectivity or the interplay of
the cells or for example also during
development
thank you
next
question why do you have to use a
different dissociation kit for the
inflamed brain
um
for the inflamed brain
so what i what i showed you here the
we recommend the multi-tissue
dissociation kit
because if you are working with the
inflamed brain and you are interested in
immune cells so in infiltrating immune
cells
um you need to make sure
or at least if you are want to isolate
those immune cells later on with our
microbeads you need to make sure that
the kit and the beads fit to each other
in case of the neural cells and the
adult brain association kit this works
but for some of our immune cells they
are quite the epitopes are quite
sensitive so the multi-tissue
dissociation kit works better so this is
why we depending a bit on the cell type
you're interested in we recommend
different kits or different
slightly different adapted workflows so
the best would be always if you have
like a really specific question in mind
to write to us or write to our tech
support then we can try to set up with
you the perfect protocol
or what products you need or what would
be suited the best
thank you
next question
is it possible to isolate microglia from
p8
mice of hippocampus region
um
yeah i think it's possible so
we have this
not only the adult brain association kit
but also for
younger mice
the
neurotician association kit p8 is kind
of in the middle let's say
[Music]
but since the i guess what you need
would be just like a small region like
the hippocampus right
um
and since the you have basically less
amount of tissue
the the workflow or the the protocol of
the adult brain association kit might be
a bit tricky so here we would recommend
a neural tissue dissociation kit
because
at p8 we don't expect so huge amount of
debris or red blood cells so you don't
really need to do those steps
[Music]
but you can still
you can still isolate them with the
beads so this should be perfectly fine
also from a small smaller brain region
and i think we even have protocols
available online
to do this specifically for small brain
regions um i can also send you some if
you want later on
but yes this is
possible
well thank you it looks like we are out
of time for questions um thank you nazar
and elisa do you have any final comments
for our audience
yes so i just would like to thank you
very much for joining our webinar today
and
if you are looking for detailed
information regarding my lawyers and
research solutions please feel free to
contact us by email or visit military
biotech website and i hope to have you
around again in our future webinars and
have a nice day or evening wherever you
are
yeah
thank you also from my side
well thank you again nizar and elisa for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank labyrutz and
our sponsor miltoni biotek for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye